going to begin this hour with the
Ukrainian president's historic visit to
Washington Vladimir zielinski and
President Biden met for a show of unity
in the Oval Office yesterday he then
later addressed a rare joint meeting of
Congress zielinski asked for more help
from the U.S as lawmakers get ready to
vote on another 45 billion dollars in
military aid for Ukraine as part of a
larger spending package
our two Nations
are allies in this battle
and next year will be a turning point I
know it the point when Ukrainian courage
and American resolve must guarantee the
future of our common Freedom the freedom
of people who stand for their values
now this was zielinski's first trip
outside of Ukraine that we know of
anyway since the Russian invasion began
10 months ago and it comes at a very
pivotal point in this war Russia
continues to Target Ukraine's vital
infrastructure leaving Millions without
power or heat in the winter coal Chief
Foreign Affairs correspondent and face a
nation moderator there she is Margaret
Brennan hi Margaret is with us from
Washington Margaret good morning to you
good morning good morning last night
when the Ukrainian president addressed
Congress he also said he was talking to
the American people and made it very
clear we need your help we need your
help now more than ever what are the
major takeaways that you could see last
night
Gail that that was it this was a sales
pitch directly to the American people
president zielinski rarely speaks in
English both times I've interviewed him
it's in Ukrainian he's most comfortable
there but he was speaking directly to
the American people and this is really a
visit he couldn't afford to skip Gail
because right now as Congress is poised
to pass the largest Ukraine age Aid
package to date we're now totaling close
to a hundred billion dollars there are
some Skeptics in Congress who are
particularly in the Republican party and
about to take power saying they want to
have more scrutiny of the aid as it
continues so he is really making the
argument as he did in that speech in an
impassioned way that this is a fight for
democracy jointly with the United States
that this is essentially a bargain he
said we can fly the planes we can drive
the tanks just continue to send them our
way and he spoke some of the language
that will land well with Republicans
underscore worrying that Iran is now
part of the fight helping Russia so this
was really a sales pitch to the American
people to say thank you and to appeal to
their common humanity and it was
lightning fascale he was here less than
10 hours and I've never seen a standing
ovation like that speaker Pelosi had to
tell lawmakers sit down
it was long and prolonged Margaret I as
I watched the speech he and his
Battlefield greens speaking in English
getting so many standing ovations I
thought I wonder what Vladimir Putin is
thinking in Russia if he's watching or
hearing I mean how does this go over
with him and them
well uh it it of course is being noted
when uh zielinski makes this daring trip
to the White House to you know the
capital of a super power and the largest
sort of Arsenal of this democracy
um and to date peskov the uh
spokesperson for Vladimir Putin has said
that this just shows the United States
just wants war that there is no interest
in peace I think two things that were
clear here in zelinski's remarks he was
trying to speak to those who are
Skeptics of the war also saying he wants
peace saying he presented President
Biden with a 10-point peace plan but
Vladimir Putin isn't the one willing to
negotiate and also that they need more
weapons
um we are at a point where Ukraine is
expecting a new Russian offensive Russia
controls 18 percent of that country and
it is cold they're weaponizing the cold
weather turning off the electricity
freezing civilians this is about to get
even more brutal and so the message to
Russia here is that the United States
will at least for now continue the
funding the package that's about to pass
is expected to last through about May of
2023 but president zielinski said
honestly it's not enough weaponry
Margaret you mentioned president
zielinski saying things that scored well
with the Republicans but some
Republicans actually missed the address
because they oppose the funding of this
war how do you see all of this playing
out as it pertains to the political
tension between the parties
well you know to date Nate when people
would ask me is there anything
bipartisan in Washington I'd say two
things China and Ukraine that's now
changing
um the Republicans were taking control
of the house some of them including the
man presumed to be in leadership Kevin
McCarthy as well as Steve scalise who's
going to be one one of the key leaders
in the Republican Party have said there
will be more accountability there will
be more scrutiny of Aid saying it won't
be a blank check that's not saying Aid
will be cut off but it's signaling that
some of those more right-wing members
who have protested zielinski's visit do
find an audience with them at least to a
certain point
Margaret Brennan happy holidays and
thank you
holidays to you too